the following trailer is rated s for
spoilers for stuff that happened 80
years
[Music]
ago from a pale genius who's cold
principled and unfairly maligned comes a
Nolan film about that same kind of guy
for like the what fifth time now he's
got a type Oppenheimer
meet J Robert Oppenheimer a man smart
enough to understand tenet on the first
watch Robert you see beyond the world we
live in he's the rare nutting Professor
who may not have what it takes in the
lab useless in the lab would you like to
help build it oh no Oppenheimer couldn't
run a hamburger stand I couldn't but
he's the only man you call when you need
a theoretical physicist you're talking
about turning Theory into a practical
weapon system/ meteorologist it'll break
Before Dawn how could you know that I
know this desert SL polylinguist you
learned enough Dutch in 6 weeks to get a
lecture on quantum mechanics and now I
am become death destroyer of worlds oh
I've readal all three volumes in the
original German okay okay we get it
normally when a guy wants to convince us
he's this smart he just buy Twitter
experience a site that's equal parts
haunting and beautiful extreme closeup
of Killy in Murphy's face
oh as he adopts a permanent bugy stare
that screams one is science done or just
as likely help I'm a skeleton who runs
on cigarettes yeah I think the honey on
the rim of the martini glass that was
that was his nutrition the only
calorific
in in this powerful performance that
exposes every inch of him for you to
judge
we were so close to killing four days of
history class with this but you just had
to go and hang dong huh back to fat man
and little boy on VHS then it's all
about ass isn't it sir you kick it what
you lick
it no giggling settle in for a 3-hour
film that's kind of like Inception I'm
teaching something no one here has Dred
of if every layer of dream was a
different Congressional subcommittee
it's now trial about a try telling
oppenheimer's story through a cabinet
confirmation hearing why were his
communist associations not seen as a
security risk during the war about a
security clearance renewal process my
involvement leftwing groups would not
prove AAR to my working on the atomic
program regarding an informal Round
Table what were you guys doing in Los
Alamos wasn't secured time of course it
was and a rockus joint committee session
isotop are less useful than electronic
components but more useful than a
sandwich that ends in a shocking twist
the man Robert embarrassed at the aec
secretly handpicked the greyboard
special prosecutor gasp uh I can see I
lost you there huh uh big bomb goes
boom Cinema rules prepare for a long ass
movie that keeps you hooked by trotting
at a new beloved actor every 10 minutes
like Robert Downey Jr's triumphant
return after whatever this
[Music]
was who's moved on from Tony Stark by
playing a businessman weapons developer
with a massive ego in black and white
Emily Blunt steals every scene as Kitty
Oppenheimer who's there to literally
drink and no things wake up smart move
by Robert to make her his hand and mad
Davon plays a guy pushing a technology
he doesn't understand so we all knew
he'd nailed a role fortune favors the
brave and every physicist you've ever
heard of pops up to reminisce about this
one time at bomb Camp non Einstein
though he's not invited great a
scientific mind of our time of his time
how many people do you know proved
Einstein wrong I'm not sure you
understand Albert yeah take a hike
Einstein E equals MC
Square stick around for a film with more
going on than his usual time wank dead
woman boy Genius bit there's also some
thoughtful engagement with American
politics meditations on guilt and
responsibility and the perspective of
the Japanese and Native people most
directly affected by the bombs in a film
with a nuanced message we may one day be
engulfed by nuclear fire all thanks to J
Robert Oppenheimer but he felt wee we we
bad about it okay sorry about the
apocalypse e so bunker up for the least
likely Blockbuster of the summer that's
probably no one's best film yet proving
audiences will support and enjoy stories
with extremely serious grown-up subject
matter but still nothing could be
funnier than someone watching this
because Barbie memd them into the
theater do you guys ever think about
dying I do now
constantly
starring Irish darong Kitty Pride Opie
doesn't know hater raid flow the
progressive
boring relativity media Jesse we need to
cook worst casy scenario Bohemian
testimony uncut nuclei Fain interest 10
Things I Hate About boom Josh Harnet in
classes so unattractive Red Scare
Redemption and the alternate reality
where the fate of the world rests on
Josh P better than Drake Bell I guess
the Big Bang
Theory love is the one thing we're
capable of perceiving that transcends
dimensions of time in space it's not
possible do you love Nolan check out our
Deep dive into his whole filmography in
the by the Numbers thumbnail on the
right do you love a bunch of nerds
working on a massive project Gamespot
interviewed a dozen cyberpunk 2077 devs
on the changes they made to their studio
and the game after release in the
thumbnail on the
left I am
KF up up up up inimer style he was in
the Amazon with my mom when she was
researching spiders right before she
died with great voice Powers comes great
Honest
Trailers